welcome back to be rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and now that Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is out it's time for us
here at new rockstars to face our makers
and address the many predictions we got
wrong wrong sir wrong in the lead-up to
this film normally this is an annual
tradition but we decided hey let's just
start doing this after every big movie
we make predictions for and this video
is brought to you by Squarespace more on
them later everyone's saying rocket and
I say He Lives who are they gonna kill
they're gonna kill Drax baby and I think
Star-Lord could be looking at a demise
here okay so I was right about rocket
not dying I don't think I get points for
that though he technically kind of died
for a few seconds did Star-Lord die for
a couple of seconds when he was in outer
space maybe can I get a quarter of a
point for that I'm glad they didn't kill
anyone rocket is gonna die and I think
that Drax is gonna die
Dan didn't want to kill off these
beloved creatures just because they're
moving on to other things if it's not
Rocky then it's probably Lilith but all
my chips are Lila and uh should not be
so happy about it auto day I think Drax
is gonna die I think cragland might die
and because Marvel always kills off
their villains I think Herbert windham's
gonna die yeah turns out no one died in
this movie which is a good thing
characters can totally have their
stories end and move on to a next phase
without them having to die Star Wars
going down in this one Peter Quill when
his face puffed up I was like come on
not that I would root for Peter Quill's
death but I'm competitive so I do root
for being right but no deaths I believe
that craglin is the most likely to die
in Garden Street okay I seriously
thought Cracklin was going to die in
this movie because James Gunn seriously
loves to kill off his friends and family
like you know Michael Rooker and Sean
Gunn as well so I'm very surprised that
shotgun made it but I'm very happy to be
wrong because I love shotgun on this
Team Rocket and Drax baby bye bye well
listen I think I was right on both
accounts one rocket coated on the table
and it had to be brought back to life so
he technically died and drax's social
life is dead now that he has 54 adopted
children
well Howard the Duck is gonna show up I
think we might see Michael Rooker as
some form of yondu but I think the
surprise twist is that Benicio del Toro
is going to show up as tanelier Tavon
The Collector yeah I was right about
Howard the Duck but I was also right
about yondu that's exciting meanwhile
The Collector Channel complete no-show
like Guardians show up in Thor's movie I
think the war could show up again okay
to be fair we didn't really get any
cameos in this movie from other like
Marvel uh characters so no points for me
I'm gonna say Wonder Man okay so I was
completely wrong Wonder Man did not show
up to the Watcher yeah I was just dead
wrong about that one
Arnold Schwarzenegger baby where were
you Arnold you didn't show up in the
movie you're costing me valuable points
here Molly Ringwald Matthew Broderick or
Pamela Anderson baby
none of those people made a cameo I
don't know what to tell you I was just
really really wrong I'm really sorry
Joan Jett is she dead Okay so first off
Joan Jett isn't dead Joan Jett is very
much still alive uh was not in this at
all not even Joan Jett music we're gonna
get payoffs for all the babes the ships
have been named after Pat Benatar Alyssa
Milano coming in hot okay uh no Alyssa
Milano no Pat Benatar no happy Tommy B
okay I was still happy the movie still
rocked I think since this is the last of
this Trilogy Alyssa Milano's gotta make
a cameo here yeah no Kevin Bacon no
Alyssa Milano you know I'm rooting for
Kevin Bacon to come back come on back
Kevin Bacon if if it's any time it's now
it counts he was in the in a little
photo he was in the post-credits scene
on the newspaper I think that counts his
face
during the run time into accounts
there's no way the Footloose doesn't get
referenced okay though Peter cool did
not reference Footloose in the movie we
did get that little picture of Kevin
Bacon during the credits I think that we
are going to go through the very sad
discovery that Star-Lord has when he
realizes that the lead singer of Nirvana
Kurt Cobain is dead okay that I actually
think still could happen because he's on
earth now baby his Grandpa's gonna catch
him up on stuff his grandpa looks like
he was a huge Nirvana fan I mean just
look at the guy definitely right since
we have Adam Warlock in this he's a
character against cocoon I wonder if
we'll get a reference to the Ron Howard
movie yeah no cocoon I should have known
that Patrick Swayze would have been
referenced it could have gone all the
way in reference ghost that would have
been really cool instead we just got
kind of a loose homage to ghost in the
form of that scene with Lila yeah the
high evolutionary he's got that like
gray Skull action going on I nailed it
on this one he called him Grace golf it
was perfect I'm the Champion I should
get 100 points for that I killed it I
should win this whole thing just based
on that I'm in the Zeitgeist I
understand I am Star-Lord I got it
we could see the birth from Adam
warlock's evil counterpart the Magus
okay I'm a little bit upset that we did
not see the Magus in the post credit
scene for this movie but I do understand
because this is the very beginning of
Adam warlock's story so like throwing in
the Magus might be a little bit too
early Moon Knight is just gonna appear
and go
I don't know I wish that that happened
that would have been really fun one of
the post-credits scenes is going to be
the Silver Surfer I do believe that
there was some surfing but it wasn't
silver I said The Collector being on
Earth and I got half of it right we're
gonna see some of the eternals Adam
warlock's gonna come on the ship and be
like this is my ship now where are we
going I want to hang out with you guys
okay we did get Adam Warlock in a
post-credits scene I don't even think he
flies he does run a little bit yep once
again no Galactus no Silver Surfer I
don't know why the MCU is dragging their
feet with those guys but yeah lesson
learned at the end of these series they
tend not to do these huge explosive
reveals for their post-credit scenes
look we're gonna get back to the video
in a second but I gotta tell you about
Squarespace not only are they making it
possible for me to make this video but
they could be making it possible for you
to do honestly whatever you want to do
online that's because Squarespace makes
it easy to make an awesome website that
lets you engage with your audience and
sell anything you need your products
content you create even your time
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online if you're into making
videos Squarespace can help you create
Pro level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales but hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media buff well no problem you
can display posts from any profile you
want on your website and automatically
push website content to your favorite
social media channels so your followers
can share it too no matter what you're
doing squarespace's analytics tools will
help you learn where your traffic and
sales are coming from and so you can
improve your website and build a
marketing strategy based on either your
top keywords or most popular products
and content head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
Mr Adam
really confidently I'm saying that that
was a weird guess I'm not really sure
what inspired me to say Adam Warlock
there but to be fair if I was gonna go
back and regress it probably would have
been a nebula and I would have been
wrong anyway mantis nebula and Gamora
okay so I was wrong uh there actually
were none of those women still leading
the Guardians at the end of that movie
I was completely wrong in my prediction
it was at mantis and it wasn't Star-Lord
it's Now Rocket my best bet is that
mantis will end up being the new
I totally understand why she didn't she
has to find her own way like she was
under ego that she was under the
guardian so it's like she sort of has to
like figure out who mantis is I really
do hope that we see mantis in Vision
Quest they have a relationship in the
comics so that'd be really fun this is
gonna be her full Arc from True bad all
the way to being true good okay okay
nebula is not leading the guardian she's
not even on the Guardians anymore she
wants to run nowhere she wants to build
that place make it beautiful make it fun
my bad nebula trying to keep your work
if you're here to retire you want to be
the grief cargo of outer space baby and
I get it I think the leaders of the
Guardians will be nebula and or rocket
haha nailed it nebula and Rocket well
really just rock it but nebula is
leading whatever the contingent is on
nowhere
I think all the Guardians will stay on
the Guardians that aren't dead okay I
never said I was good at predicting
these things I never said that but I did
get Layla being dead right I feel like a
team is gonna stick together
they reset the teamwork does not make
the dream work and everyone has
individual dreams I did say quill was
gonna go home to find himself so half
points maybe group mantis and nebula go
on a big space journey together it was
sort of right like rude is sort of sort
of staying a little bit nebula fraglin
and mantis and that's it everyone
survived as we saw great love to see it
people left I got the wrong people
leaving of course rocket and group stick
around they love it they love being on
the guardian yeah so I think nebula and
rocket and Bruce I think mantis is going
to be around I think Cosmo is gonna
stick around as member of this group
since everyone in this movie survived
yeah I got this one right too
we're gonna find out about xandar in
this movie they're gonna answer all our
questions that we had okay I'm so angry
about this because I put this question
into the predictions question video I
want to know about xandar someone tell
us about xandar what happened yes I
think we'll explore xandar or at least
the cops we did not get into xandar but
we did get into the cops I don't think
we're gonna go yeah we didn't go to
xandar it's like jazz it's what they
didn't say about xandar that informed me
about it so I'm gonna give myself points
on that I am honestly shocked that we
did not see the Nova Corps in any
fashion during this movie considering
the highly illegal activities of the
high evolutionary the entirety of all of
his experiments on different planets I
thought that you know that would be on
Nova's radar but then again they were
destroyed so
you know kind of busy it wouldn't
surprise me at all if James Gunn at
least addresses it in this third movie
ah you know why we do not season are in
this movie or get any kind of reference
to the Nova core they do reference
xandar
GE counter Earth nebula says the gravity
of the planet is xandar minus one so I
think I was half right by saying xandar
would get reference we're not hearing
about Sam
I will say
saves left out of the video that I
actually did get right I believe that
counter Earth will be destroyed by the
high evolutionary for the purposes of
making a Celestial being himself this
dude loves to play God and what better
way to play God than to birth a literal
God that did not happen but he still
destroyed it I knew that that was going
to happen so I'm going to take that as a
win destruction of counter Earth Adam
Warlock is going to kill the higher
evolution
I was so wrong so wrong about so much of
this but uh
yeah great movie rocket isn't gonna die
die
honestly I thought the biggest twist was
that Drax lives though Wild Card big
twist is that Gamora winds up on Earth
and Valentina gets her to join the
Thunderbolts my prediction didn't happen
at all she is still with the ravagers
and she is probably better off with the
ravages than ever being on the
Thunderbolts team so I was completely
wrong 90 of the time but I still had fun
doing it using time travel nebula and
Gamora are gonna go back in time they're
gonna rescue baby rocket and all of his
cute little animal friends before they
get got by the weird scientist man guy I
wish that that happened Peter quell he's
gonna be like you know what I'm going
back to Earth and when he tries to go
back to Earth Nick Fury kills him okay
again half right on this one Peter Quill
wanted to go back to Earth see his
grandpa Jason learn about who he is be
on earth half right there Nick Fury
didn't kill him yet watch your back
Peter Quill because Nick Fury doesn't
want you around so I think we might end
up getting another baby rocker raccoon
though Rockets did not end up dying in
this movie we did end up getting some
baby raccoons being saved by rocket I
think this movie will be the one to
genetically identify everybody with a
Celestial link as a mutant in the Marvel
world uh yeah I I really didn't get this
one right and yeah this movie didn't say
the word mutant anywhere in there in the
whole genetic history of mutant kind of
the MCU is still a very big mystery yeah
I think it's still very possible that
the yellow fluid that we see throughout
this movie especially in the Oregon
facility could be that same yellow fluid
that they were mining from the skull of
nowhere and that this goo could have
still been Celestial derived they just
didn't explicitly say it in this movie
and it remains a theory that I'll be
beating the drum of overall I think a
lot of the stuff I predicted for this
movie was pretty accurate the fact that
we got a Herbert window based off that's
something that I was predicting hard for
this character and a lot of the general
plot points the fact that we visit
counter Earth the fact that rocket was
created by Herbert Windham the high
evolutionary that's something I
predicted years ago and that recently
after the first trailer I predicted that
Herbert Windham The Sovereign and that
Adam Warlock were all connected and this
movie totally confirmed that pervert
Windham created The Sovereign I guess I
didn't go as hard with my theories for
this one but I didn't would be more
accurate which is pretty surprising to
me but also a little disappointing it's
more fun for me when I'm way off base
hey on May 26th in Los Angeles
California Tommy and me and Jessica and
the new rockstars crew are gonna escape
the blue dungeon and get on stage in
front of a live in-person audience it's
gonna be such a fun show there's gonna
be special guests ridiculous comedy bits
exclusive videos we can never ever ever
show on YouTube to get in-person tickets
click the link in the description below
if you can't make it to LA on May 26th
you can stream the worldwide digital
experience from our partners at moment
that link is also in the description so
that is what we got wrong and right
trying to predict Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. who would have thought
that all the Guardians have survived
this movie don't forget to check out all
of our awesome Guardians of the Galaxy
content here on new rockstars Channel
and be sure to subscribe to our other
channels to Deep dive in the break room
you can support the channel and pick up
some awesome merch at nerd riot.shop
follow me at eavos and follow new
rockstars on all social platforms thanks
for watching bye
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]